Mr Street in good to talk to you just a
thought on what we saw in Nottingham
yesterday morning and the loss of these
two youngsters and a 51 year old man
these kids 19 years old their whole
lives ahead of them
um good morning hey first of all my
heart goes out to the family of those
who've lost their lives and you know I
know that we're still anxiously waiting
news about other people who were injured
in the course of what happened it's an
unspeakable Unthinkable tragedy I cannot
imagine what these families and their
friends are going through and I know for
the people of Nottingham students of
Nottingham University more broadly
I think people are really struggling to
to process and comprehend the news so I
think at this stage we've got to await
the outcome of the police investigation
to understand the motive of the attacker
see what news emerges and of course if
anyone has any information
um about you know the person involved or
the circumstances or witnessed anything
then they should they should contact the
police but it's a terribly desperately
sad time for the people of Nottingham
and I joined Nottingham's labor MPS in
sending my
um my heart out to everyone involved and
and support the police as they undertake
what is undoubtedly
um in our awful investigation for the
officers to be involved in yeah indeed
so um three other people
um treated in hospital one of them in a
critical condition after what happened
it makes us realize just how much we
treasure our National Health Service
um how are you going to save the NHS
without injecting loads more cash
well okay I know that investment is
needed and we've already made some
specific commitments the biggest
expansion of NHS staff in history 1.6
billion pounds funded by abolishing the
non-dom tax status and one of the
arguments that I'm making today I'm
speaking to NHS leaders up here in in
Manchester I'm speaking to you from
Salford this morning
um the argument I'm making is that
um
even if the public finances weren't in a
terrible mess which thanks to the
conservatives they are even if the NHS
weren't in the biggest crisis in its
history which I think it objectively is
we would still need some change of
modernization in the NHS and partly
because
um with an aging population the nature
of disease and the sorts of conditions
we're living with look very different
now than they did in 1948 also more
positively we're sitting on top of a
revolution that's taking place in
medical technology Life Sciences AI
machine learning and if we deploy the
technology that already exists let alone
the stuff that's coming down the track
more effectively we can deliver better
outcomes for patients and also free UPS
precious staff time so for example if we
used AI in the analysis of scans for
breast cancer breast cancer diagnosis
then we can free up about 30 of
radiologist capacity and improve
diagnosis and detection by about 16 so
better for patients freeing up staff
time and making sure we're using the
money that's already going into the NHS
to greatest effect and and in a time
where despite all the promises uh to ax
the facts and Purge the pager we still
see these devices being used I think you
know talk to people who work in the NHS
it's a far cry from a modern National
Health Service and a labor government
would commit to working with the NHS we
only have to find out much of time as
you know Mr streeting so um are you
saying you wouldn't inject any more
money into the NHS then
I'm saying investment is needed but
reform is also necessary
and we're emphasizing that we'll look
we'll set out our full plans at the next
general election K but in a refrain that
is going to become hopefully already is
familiar but it's going to become more
familiar we are being very very careful
about the promises that we make in terms
of spending but I've got to tell you
every time I think things can't get
worse with this economy with the
conservatives they do inflation is not
falling in the way that was expected and
predicted interest rates are rising ask
anyone like me who's renewed his
mortgage this week what's going on there
and the economy is not in a good State
and we've got to be hard-headed and
realistic about what a labor government
might inherit so we are thinking about
our priorities
what rate did you get
well I'm lucky in that I renewed with my
existing lender so my rate came in at
about you know I think it was 4.33 in
the end
um but I'm paying hundreds of pounds
more a month now look not asking your
viewers to get out the world's smallest
violin for me I'm gonna cope but I am
really worried about all of those
families for whom that sort of increase
is the difference between keeping your
head above water or going under I'm
really worried about the state the
economy and the Public Finance a shadow
yeah a shadow Health secretary I want to
ask you about a story that really
exercised our viewers um yesterday it's
in a lot of the papers again today with
think pieces about it
um the woman that is spending 28 months
in jail for her late
um abortion she took pills um the
10-week pills much later which she got
in the post during the pandemic should
we decriminalize abortion
this is an unspeakably awful face first
of all let me say K and
um I'm a horrified that such a late
stage termination took place I'm
horrified at what we've already learned
about the circumstances in which this
occurred and also I don't mind saying
I'm horrified at the idea of a mother of
three children being put behind bars you
know my mum was born in prison I I know
the impact of having parents
um in my case grandparents in the
criminal justice system the impact that
has on families and I I've got to be
careful what I say because I think
there's going to be an appeal in this
case
um I don't think we should Mr cheating
I'm asking you that I'm asking you
whether labor thinks we should
decriminalize abortion Lucy power your
colleague was here yesterday she says it
certainly needs to be looked into what
do you think you're the shadow Health
secretary
well we don't have any sentencing
guidelines at the moment and thankfully
that's because these cases are
exceptionally rare I I think
um in terms of a difficult and sensitive
issue such as this I think probably the
best thing to do at this stage is let
the appeal run through see what the
outcome of the judicial process is in
this case and then take a bit of a step
back and look in the broadest sense at
where the law is how it's applied and
crucially because this is how I approach
it as the person who wants to be our
country's Health secretary I want to
make sure as someone who believes very
strongly in a woman's right to choose
that every woman is able to exercise
that right in a timely way in a safe way
and in a legal way so that no woman is
ever in a situation where she would even
contemplate
um breaking the law and the abortion
time limit in the third time I must ask
you a third time do you think that
abortion should be decriminalized here
in England
uh well as I say kay I I I do think that
we've got to look in the broadest sense
that how the law is constructed I think
we should do that after this case
concludes and not through the prism of
this case I'm not comfortable with the
idea of criminalizing women you know as
a as a abortion as a conscience issue uh
it's for every Member of Parliament to
make their decision I'm not comfortable
with with the situation as it is but as
we have seen with this case and with I
think the last case was 10 years ago
even worse I would argue than this one
but we've got to be really it's a really
difficult and sensitive area and one
that I don't mind admitting you know
we're not as politicians we're not
supposed to admit vulnerability or
uncertainty we're supposed to be
definitive and sure on everything I
don't mind admitting as someone who's
very very strongly supports a woman's
right to choose that this case and and
ones like it thankfully rare raise
really really difficult ethical issues
that I think we should look at and
consider in a in a in a thoughtful
compassionate and considered way but I
don't I don't pretend to have all of the
answers this morning okay just before I
let you go I want to ask you about the
one of the select committees um that is
meeting uh today to hear from the head
of ITV and they'll be talking
um about what happened with Phillip
Schofield and the greater culture uh
within ITV and the chair of that
committee Caroline dionage was on the
program last week and she was saying to
me that you know at Para
she was saying that some television
presenters can be seen and treated as TV
gods do you think that TV presenters are
too big for their boots
there are lots of answers I could give
I'm not sure if I'm brave enough I I
worship at the altar of K Burley she's a
brilliant presenter um and uh you know I
just I'm glad I'm at this end and not
within arms for each of you this morning
unfortunately you'd be able to see a one
there but it's always good to see you
Wes thanks very much Lee for joining us
thanks a lot excuse Kate